the aftermath continues for Harry and
Megan but for King Charles he found the
perfect distraction in Deadpool Ryan
Reynolds telling the king welcome to
wrexham
tonight
yup that's Ryan and Rob mcelhaney
meeting chatting up and posing with the
king and queen consort Camilla today on
a rushed outing in Wales
cracking jokes the group mingled inside
it also took this shot with players from
wrexham the Welsh football team Ryan and
Rob bought on a whim back in 2020. how
did you explain this to your wife I'm
not that dumb Kevin I promise you I
would consult my wife before putting
pants on
um she's as obsessed as I am she's
already like looking at the schedule
throughout the year wondering which
matches she can attend meanwhile six
more days until part two of Harry and
Megan's dock drops on Netflix one new
report says next week will be poison for
the palace this is when a family and a
family business are in direct conflict
everything that's happened to us was
always going to happen to us the king
and queen consort they can't really
answer back if this is the path they
choose to take so be it we'll only
intervene if there is anything deeply
damaging episodes four through six
seemingly focus on megsit and with the
couple's privacy please they're getting
some scathing reviews the New York Post
calls the doc a hypocritical attention
Grab the Wall Street Journal a royal
pity party and from The Hollywood
Reporter it took a lot of time to reveal
very little suddenly what clicked in my
head was it's never going to stop I said
we need to get out of here
it's quite clear that Harry holds a lot
of grudges
back to all the Privacy backlash Harry
and Megan's Global press secretary told
us quote the Duke and Duchess have never
cited privacy as the reason for stepping
back this distorted narrative was
intended to trap the couple into silence
look to all the haters I love this thing
because I love hearing their side of the
story